a little about me my name is Ryan this
is my github and Twitter handle and
stuff and has a little bit of an
advertisement I work at ascribe our
flagship product is called big chain DB
which is a blockchain database and if
you're interested in that somewhat
controversial topic you can come back to
this room around 4:30 and hear the CEO
of our company talk about it so to get
on the same page we should know what I
mean when I say a similar image these
two images are similar and we say they
have sort of perceptual similarity in
the sense that if you were some kind of
alien and didn't know what the Mona Lisa
was and didn't know what a cat was you
could probably guess that these images
are pretty similar as opposed to
content-based or conceptual similarity
even though they kind of have the same
color scheme you really need to know
what a tiger is - to know that this is
two pictures of tiger in different
positions so our image library is just
focusing on the top kind the simpler
kind in some sense and we're ignoring
this content-based similarity this has
been done before of course you're
probably wondering what I'm doing here
I'm sure you just tonight tonight is a
great image reverse image search for
finding you know if you have an image
you can find out where it's being used
on the web there's also this library
called P hash which which gives you the
perceptual hashes from different kinds
of images the problem here is of course
TinEye is a service it's not open source
software so it couldn't we're limited in
how we could build things around it and
PS just provides the image hashing it
doesn't necessarily tell you how to
search among a billion plus images so in
the end we wrote the whole thing also PS
has a the lice it's open source but the
license is non-commercial so we decided
to write the whole thing for ourselves
from scratch the approach we use is
based on this paper the dates not here
this is from Xerox early 2000s it's not
particularly bleeding-edge but we
couldn't
with there's like a reference
implementation of it here but it's quite
old code it's not maintained so we
wanted to be able to use it in Python of
course the whole thing that we did is
Python numpy and want to be able to use
it with modern databases so the basic
idea is you've got some kind of image
here and you need to compute it you need
to change it into something that the
computer can understand which usually
means some kind of vector or list of
numbers and then of course you need a
way to search it very quickly so it's
not just enough to be able to compare
directly to images you have to be able
to find if one image or similar images
in your database of a billion images and
you know around a second or something or
it's kind of not useless for or not
useful for web applications or the end
user so I'm gonna talk about how we
generate the image signature based on
the paper I showed you this is not the
only way to make a perceptual hash and
if you've you've seen this kind of thing
before this should be very familiar if
not it should be hopefully quite
interesting basically the first thing we
do is get rid of the color data just
make it black and white so a grayscale
then we kind of superimpose this little
grid on it and we're actually doing a
big data reduction here we're just
getting rid of all the information
outside those highlighted grid points so
each one you know looks like this kind
of meaningless blob of something then we
just zoom in on all those so we've got
we've reduced this images now to just a
bunch of little squares of pixels and
then we sample it so we just this is
again just so you know this is just
zoomed in then we kind of just smooth
over each one of those zones and get you
know one grayscale pixel so we've
reduced this image now to this kind of
block of shades so what do we do with
that then it's still not necessarily
something a computer can understand we
have to make the signature somehow and
the way we do that again prescribed by
the paper I showed you earlier is we we
take we look at one pixel in its
neighbors or one grid point
and it's neighbors so you can see we're
gonna look at this one highlighted in
red and it's eight neighbors then we
just if you can see this arrow sorry
it's not super clear there's a little
green arrow and a little green number
you can see that this this block it's
pointing to from the middle block is a
little bit darker so we encode that as a
one this one's about the same so we
encode it as a zero
this one's darker this one's much darker
and so on and we do this at every point
and we would combine all these together
we've got a bunch of vectors and then
basically you just flatten the whole
thing and you get what the image
signature is so if we were using a nine
by nine grid with each of the eight
nearest neighbors you get a 648
dimensional vector okay so what can we
do with this whoops okay it looks
different here so going back to the
signature from the last slide we've got
this signature from this image of the
astronaut and of course this is just a
vector this is just a direction in space
so if I take another image say this
Botticelli painting I can make a new
signature and then the image difference
is just yeah the vector difference or in
this case just a normalized vector
difference so you reduce the difference
between any two images to a single
number which is very useful so of course
this this number means nothing to you if
you can't see a few examples so here's a
few Mona Lisa's of course as we expect
the distance from an image to itself is
zero this next image maybe you can tell
maybe not from sitting out there the hue
is a little bit different the colors
different it's it's another photograph
of the painting maybe taking it a
different lighting condition then this
one has a cat and yeah so and it's it's
also robust against these kinds of
transformations like distortions small
rotations crop a little bit of cropping
that kind of thing so yeah that's a
overview of what the
different image distances might look
like of course that's just the first
part like I said we've generated the
image signatures but we need some kind
of way to search it so the way I explain
this to people in my company some of
whom were non-technical was with an
analogy of a library and I'm sure all of
you know about the difference business
between linear and binary search but I'm
gonna use this metaphor anyway just to
remind you so if you had a library of
books and you wanted to find a specific
book there's a really stupid way you
could look you could just look at every
book one after another one per second
and then you've got you know if your
blogger has a hundred thousand books
it's gonna take about 50,000 seconds on
average to find any given book unless
you get really lucky and it only takes
one second of course the better way is
to index this somehow and any if you've
ever used the library or a card catalog
or these days you know some kind of
computer you know you look it up by
subject
maybe the row the Shelf blah blah blah
so if these indexing steps take a fixed
amount of time you generally save a lot
of time right because you only have to
do a linear search on maybe the Shelf
just look down the shelf and find your
book so of course the more the story is
indexed your library or in our case
index your database of images of course
it's not straightforward and how to do
that because we've got this huge vector
so we have to break it up somehow so the
way we do it is to look look at it in
pieces so if I look at these first I
guess that's 18 numbers look at this
first chunk we want to convert this into
something that's easily indexable so
I'll just go through the algorithm we
chop it up into sections we simplify it
here you can see we're kind of
compressing the range from negative 2 to
2 to negative 1 to 1 this is just to
limit the search space otherwise it's
going to explode then we make every
section non-negative and you just have
to bear me with me for a second to see
why this is so we're just adding 1 to
everything to go from 0 to 2 then we
have 3 possibilities at every point in
the vector so if I use a base 3
numbering system I can get a unique
integer if I
multiply every power of three times
every number in this vector and that's
exactly what we do we carry out this
multiplication and then you get this
unique integer and the unique integer is
exactly what will index and if you know
anything about databases indexing on
integers is a lot faster than indexing
on arbitrary objects at least in my
experience so these numbers we do this
for you know it's arbitrary how many you
want to do we do 63 by default and they
can overlap it's fine it improves the
search so these are the indexes this
this tells you where to find the image
and if there's a billion images or so so
in our analogy our database and in our
case we have a driver written for
elasticsearch we use the elastic search
because we also cared about how quickly
we could append images and we found with
the small elastic search clusters and a
few workers we could insert 10,000 or so
images a second into our into our log
it's Lucene based so it's quite fast so
that's in the analogy the library of
course the books and shell are the rows
and shelves and stuff are the indexes
and your individual book is their
individual image so I want to say a
little bit about the performance take
these plots with a grain of salt these
are from the original paper the database
is quite synthetic these are the recall
rates but they give you an idea of what
this is and isn't robust against as I
showed you before with the resizing and
distortion of the mona lisa
since you're super posing and
superimposing a grid and taking
differences between grid points there's
not a huge you know you can distort it a
lot and still get decent matches of
course once you start to rotate it even
by a few degrees you can put the those
shaded regions in different regions so
it's not as good the point is it can
well the point is it's not good against
rotation but it we do have building
capabilities for like 90-degree
rotations
nothing sophisticated it just rotates
the image and does another search but
that's nice because you don't have to
it's good against cropping and you can
even invert the colors do any kind of
flipping transform or combination
thereof and it should still find your
image as for the performance of the
lookup and stuff itself we aim for this
logarithmic performance and it does
indeed show unfortunately I don't have
it up to 1 billion images the cluster
you're using we are no longer using so I
didn't have it on so this is just what I
could throw together on my desktop
yesterday but you can see that the you
can see the logarithmic performance and
if you extrapolate
you know from 1 million to 10 million
hundred million a billion you're
probably still looking at under a second
lookup times so it's quite fast and yeah
a couple other projects people have made
based on image match one simply called
match it's made by some people at Pavlov
machine learning which is a company in
San Francisco I don't know much about
them but if you want to deploy this on
kubernetes if that's what you're into
this is what you want to use also
another internal project we have is
basically like image match for 3d models
since we have some 3d printing customers
and we've open sourced this as well so
it's nothing
it's basically image match with a
blender plugin that Orient's whatever
model you give it into the specific
orientations and then you just search
over those images just like there were
regular images one thing I want to add
we were surprised that the popularity of
this project because we even when we
were building it we assumed someone had
done this before but we've you know put
it on Hacker News and reddit and github
and no one's ever told me of an
open-source version of the alternative
of image match that exists so if you
know something during the questions
please let me know because I've never
heard of it when I acknowledge a few
people - two of whom are here today
Sylvain is here somewhere
sylvain and Alberto working in a scribe
helped with the open sourcing of this
project I wrote all the numerical code
but I'm you know you know how it can be
when you just write the scientific code
and you want to open source it and the
other developers are like wait we've got
to actually do something about this and
onal use it so they made it useful put
it on the Python package index and
smooth the install and everything andres
muller also here in the back helped us
get the clustering and database stuff
set up as i said it runs on
elasticsearch but before he got his
hands on the project i initially had it
running on MongoDB which is kind of
funny in retrospect so we never would
have gotten 10,000 image insertions a
second anything like that without his
help for match 3d I got a lot of help
from Troy Makani who helped solve some
of the mathematical problems about
orienting the 3d models and so on and
yeah I'm quite a bit under time so I
guess I'll plenty of time for questions
thank you all the images except for this
one were what's the word public domain
this one required attribution so here it
is and here are the links again and
thank you for listening